Where did it start for you were. You were not ready for marriage for proof. So where did it start when I started.
I mean I was turning in with people stunned
or I had my age you can say don't don't mind something to factor in such a way that my father used to give me somebody
will convert boycotts. Unlike other kids. I like to play with eat.
I'd like to play in grade school enjoy and get happiness to do it but one in the last Huntsman that.
That was why why is what going like this.
I almost gave us came I said Why with when I keep on asking such questions that keeps.
A school in my mind so because I had been there.
You may at least general does that current flows from back to the mode of.
Clear weather and place which you had to with a straight jacket and pulls from back into the modem.
But you're doing that and we're going to go.
There's a three more bit is a quad there's no way absolutely nineteen is how they're going to screw it so that was
really cute As for me
and in the beginning I go there to buy these hoping it might be some ghost might have entered in had to got those.
I used to want some like Ghost
and we're going to see those items on the bush my the Internet about that's what it is like being in bed with ten up
are going to go through this.
I might be exposed to how discoursed exactly looks like so I tried that and I know that you had any small O.B.E.
Looking to get just one small instrument is it better not to get a small it's got on with the undead in the screws up
on the box and while that was ideally interesting but I mean which really attracted me and get a better technology
and gadgets. So I just so I just explored I just followed sort of created a so and while that that is something. Woods.
I was expecting though so I just I don't mean it's what it says for your latest problem glad I'm satisfied R.D.S.
You have finally admitted to place a bag to go in a book.
You just drag in the screw and I paid the street a little more.
So yeah one day I was here alone in my room and my parents read it out for the scalping and
when I was alone I was my notice mind kept exploding one being that makes trouble.
I would be for not all that occasional busy and all that activity but I was no doubt seen hacking gadgets
and on their dad was in the past and from my childhood.
So I so want to live my father's probably stories about what who had so one day those so one their lives are one
and that was it that daily present in their lives.
That would be because in this small boy God there was that most such good.
So how big could we get a book straight people
and those days we don't do it all that because at least for a couple of games with nosebag I mean we used to have their
books.
And Lego does the Such beautiful images that they do where interested let's give this woman that we used to do is so I
decided to close that I just I know that one small instrument is going to he's got it from somewhere and again.
On the screen you see when I just open the box.
That was really just not for me I had like I just explained that
and wow this is something done not by God like something a president that the president thought of me
and then just I just like like we had a collecting on the boards and bang was about a little bit of me so i told us.
I was calling on the subject of just pulling us out of. And wires and they were getting on and we do not go to school.
I just think that the power was off but I got us all.
They don't let any of the alleged because I don't need I doing that I didn't have any you know connection
and it's if you've started I hardly have any knowledge of clinics and components.
So I wonder why I go to school then you're going to be less dead. Again that that was a capital which wards.
And most of course enough for me to. Practically go to to do the experience I mean to do that only.
So I'm wondering and I just got completely lost in that sort of good I was completely excited.
It was going to get better than it was there's little in the esophagus and everything is completely in love
and death then stopped a few minutes I heard a beep so I just did what I was doing just to pollute
and I so much better without lifting a single dime I just bag on the suckers and on the West. I suppose it's possible.
I just read the blogs like in the school you jump to the Baird holding the book upside down and bed and screaming.
Then my father something is not come on something not of this might be it has done.
I just see the he's putting the book upside down
and something not to this activity has done let's see what he has done to my father just for being able to ask for the
note because that was a I don't need it. Night. I don't bear. They don't been B.M. Even say so.
My mom did not let out of one down once the sauce was hideous because Indians of more than two bellies full ten don't
you know madam what it would be nice Well General My mom can skew the numbers game skewed at what's in that size was he.
It's that he adds. So fast that. So my mom just relaxed on her bared about on the blog up the T.V.
Remote distances of space to work on the one going off when. House was on fire.
All my neighbors only if you let me bring in the sand. That's when I was and yes I did it. I am the scientist.
Yes I did indeed I did it I just screamed like anything yes I did it.
I'm the scientist because that they made in knowledge that the person who does something oppressing something in it.
Blushed. Then he got a scientist I know that God was the meaning of a scientist.
When I was a kid so I was screaming like anything and then all my bad
and thought of my relatives all of the neighbors the came to me I thought dead coming to upload me what I have done
but that outlawed once in such a way that my stomach was completely filled with.
All the schoolings all those Gleamings why don't they can do so in my you do was completely done better
and from that Bill No Once I was here I'll be a problem.
All those look get there's everything even not love after a few days even if you come from in neighborhoods any of the
neighboring homes and so you wouldn't believe I'm saying go to India when they want us out
and say sun is coming to your home and they will fast. Site and people.
I said that get their stand on the new list of sins on this coming.
It's either going to have any of the good some legs gotta have it from me so that was like that when I was in my club.
So I could. My best.
I'm glad technology or not but when you see gradually my passion towards innovation happened by accident.
You can see because I never thought I would make it universal I was fascinated and I was special because you get there.
But that doesn't mean that Universal Music accident.
And that happens in a way that when I was in my dance tonight when I was sixteen years old I had gone to hospital.
With my father I mean my father generally used to have a hybrid person
and he goes What are we to take up so one day just like a man and he went to the hospital and with a husband.
It's a small hospital consent clinic and my father just entered into doctor's care and I had I would I would say.
So when up to those few minutes I saw that my eyes are so outward I mean just got back in
or lids disabled person because of the or it is his hands and then we'll come to this to prevent that.
By this might have happened or that.
So I was seeing that he was sitting in a wheelchair then and he would have been assisted by
and also the day the wound of the play was of them meaning what was happening.
I just found out the puzzle of notable to speak because they came to know that seventy percent of the disease would
pull the news of the Congo out because of the
but a lot of this is so deeply spiraling to the little spinal activeness it is the I mean these activities have been so
I saw that he would not I would do express want to get the ones who are slightly able to visit hands
but not exactly able to express what they're going to let me say as you know they were the experts.
So when it was your business to handle a nonstarter.
You might and might I mean you need liquid water and something so handed over to him of less importance
and he just threw down. I mean you want something and so we're seeing their situation a deity Huntsman.
I just failed to get my myself in that position that if someone's was brain was about everything looking more due to
the goodness on the middle of the destruction of them
and so the inaudible to speak express how painful that's just me I don't I just told Dr life so it really was then that
so that flashed on my very emotional and a guy my soul learn how painfully then using that if I am I to do
and I would then life even one person I would feel more leverage and I was happy and I was satisfied.
I've empowered one person that I have brought him back in that life.
I just want to live even one person that I would be more than happy.
So I just came back to my home and people that what can I do so that they can do everything like not one who wins.
So I just kept thinking and thinking
and then finally come to a conclusion that the going to do something I will have to figure out what's the common thing
we do not want to disable person I found the brain is gone but only if it is not that user friendly.
I have a bond of love with the boss and was and will be using that in the essential properties on
but in multiple teams. It's been if you look at those what we don't act we we I love about a voice or a hand like the.
I want to move my hand in this way.
To move the hand in this room and I come on with handle in this way poorly for different. So that is the control.
So the next interesting thing that I just put out a poem which is called one and we did not get a list which is common.
That is bleeding. You know distance becomes on gum on the bottom.
This is an unknown one or the building is the one million which is common
and which is what proponents wouldn't want a man and a disabled person
and there's a big thing we're going to confront not our good the employer submitting the name in winter to get that
but it more than an order taken on you can see a small guy that can want to but it being in a magnetic inputs
and it does in this altered would this act as a single speech do multiple street jumps in
and then we also invent the options with people screaming that to make great women on top of electrical appliances so
it makes Mrs schooling which on the bus on one trip to work that option will get activated for two second group which
can then begin to. Change.
When he wants that option would like to get an opportunity if he would and the egg and option would keep him schooling.
So it would be in a simplified
when you know it is not something that can make something complicated such proof of something complicated.
It's all about how seem pretty simply what it will solve that problem that encumbered program.
So it seems we've heard some of them is always a great innovation. But I think so.
In this way it is in the US enough
and I have been near the bus on the disabled person which if he did it was a physically assisted device for the
disabled person pull him by one of them to a group they would like humans to be getting the wheel to make operating on
the elliptical appliances text messages in a space energy and cell phone and so many other activities.
You know that was your first invention the bird started. No more to come off.
Then we have up to this making you know listen I go I got my second place enough into a lot for these innocent
and productive.
And there are lots of media over this
and not everything up in all of a sudden up to making this you know was on like it featured in the many magazines
needles and I was lucky in that fame and all and I'm getting that bloody up resistance from each
and every one I would like what happened.
All of a sudden I was living in a lot more life on how this happened under Saddam.
But in the glory in it and on one thing only the when he did it.
This is not only innocent and that I realized
when I was doing pilot testing on one of the disabled person went to jail
but it was huge huge I mean the pilot doesn't have a device. He's just an additional how what I had in sugar.
I just gave up and he just to bring He just never going to finish it. And right and stopped and the need to.
Doctrine and act with the blood and soul the TS was falling from a day's work
and I realized that that was not the sort of the tears of joy
and looking that I started my from my altar tears came over
and I have that study of success which I am I to be this is the day of success.
I needed that you know was
and is being used by the not a good person from who for whom I have never been you know wisdom.
So if I am able to gain by what one does all of us on life then my you know some point
but it was all making sense from food.
So if I can name one person like that I can buy one million suddenly them then we can i mean.
It was just brought to market by I want a war not in the fall.
I'm absolutely sure not all of us are not I that we can license to any letter with a laser disembody come to the
universe on its own made in medical device.
So it's better that we should license this in a was and when you might become one who can properly man fix it.
I dare add to that finished product level they can manufacture in that level so that if a digital person can get the
maximum benefit of the free.
So I participate or not will listen to any metric company
and we are in process to do that because we don't want to come much later this innovation because it is going to end by
one million so be able to parlay so is a bit of what already established in that in this movie. Biotechnology.
Medical technology industries out here in this we will
but I seem to get labeled I thought that it should be these people who can make it to put world global public
and whom I love in that label with that finishing with that.
And with that vision they can just make it which do a good that normally would and I didn't
and second because I was off now we are focusing them songs on the universe and on woman safety where they will send.
Also it's better that not before us on WANT to believe. Yes just to focus on one day they'll meet with it.
We can give our best. So I thought that I mean many people who can give their best in these days every day.
Don't want to add to that a lot. I want to get in and begin for that.
So in this way we have to do their day will impact. This fiber quite a feat for twenty four year old. Some of the.
What I thought when I was in Section household. To draw for and why do you think it's so unique.
What you're doing see because I didn't I didn't know isn't what I find I that it existed in that perfect solution for
to solve that and government programs for everything and that is the solution but that is not a simplified solution.
I thought visibility we have that's grown that Deeks or the simplified which are sort of.
There's so many innovations out there but I feel that whether it is even the problem
and none of those I'm going to solve hundred much of them but how with what ha.
Bob how much security and how much probability of solving the problem dogmatists
and how many how much percent of the problems is being sold that matters if there is enormous
and we shall take people to know the problem if I mean it was just something ninety percent of the problem in that you
know some sort of it and when I found I just saw you post something on the Internet
and all the many other ways like I saw side plaster would do this market something where that it's kind of innocent is
dead or not any particular solution is the I don't know if I find that there is no such
but it was a solution not a good solution not a perfect solution for any of those sites
and counter problem the one thing that.
So you know isn't hard but we don't I don't buy value adding to the existing universes or book get a new Windows
and if you just don't do the lesson. So this will reveal where reduces your. Go to produce.
You see it's like this is the this illusion for an Indian problem. Or and it's for that reason that it works or is it.
Yeah it's factored fall because of looking in the name problem
but finally I found out it's not only an initial There's a bloke over them like you if you say it's a global record
U.S. Is Indian number one in the number of threads started by tax every day and every year.
Second comes but I didn't touch comes in India not in the number of labor tax every day.
That's what the current printing ideal in India comes number one because
but I don't know what happened since Google to that in getting some of it. Of our taxes.
The best to go in causing and there is no button and solution options.
Were the first to put a force on them to call this policy I want to get with what things are someone
or something is missing.
A little bit of some solutions like theirs or guns people strange
but that's me on is not who is who does that I protest because then I would try to understand the psychology of human
why.
I mean people are not using the existing you know sense of progress which is dead in the market
and one thing that to stopping them to use that is a style shipment in their on that train the dogs are not class
and I would like if that was you people think that white people to preserve their life.
I mean I was going to read them and it happens to all of us.
I don't at any just some so
and psychology did that there is a problem that a lot things that are considered over gone
when I was in that locking them up and you just ignore them. Well OK helmet.
People hardly would helmet but to save them from getting fined in any police gets them then.
That's why they're wearing helmets that thing that we feel we were not we are not this accident.
No nor wanting for the worst thing we just wind up in so they are just how confident and nothing is going to happen
and that's where they're going to take people's priorities are guns but what about the possible eat. You know.
Most have been done to do study by tax and second though they're not any kind of statistician.
I mean that both are not questionable and and Targum is that those kind of those are not winnable.
And actually that can be misused that easily.
If the person was using the people to create the gun was you using the people spray against actor that you can stand
the People's Bank and used against him and then again at the end of the same for the president and any of the gadgets.
So fasting we fall needed to do whatever it can to be snatched must last you would if you could I could not say that it
can witness
but it will be if you go down something which is it was between which is not whether we were able to assist difficult
stance. Now would there.
What to be done with a neutral that it would be too difficult to snatch as well because obviously we've become better
between a man and a woman we men is a more safe if you go to strong and in confidence phrase and in many factors
but we have to empower the women of girls by giving some value out in the public gadget or something. So we told her.
Let's improve on small Michael who don't know who don't which we know one of those are going to try to temper that if
they don't want to because it's us which is quite enough that one someone's hand if someone tries to grab the gadget
or grab any part of the hand
or somewhere just the guy going to just make that gadget contact with any part of the screen
and you get a severe pain and it would retain the mindset of the attacker.
If you get a few up and panicking that back of that you should look for that I think and
and that should be used at the last moment before that will include depending
but I'm just replacing one bending more than one like a siren will get activated which is you don't want to do want to
disable some frequency which is equal to the mall. I mean ambulance and police said I was going to get into your.
Your disposal and you could create havoc in the environment and you could get a few in the.
Keep that if you're in back in that article and at the same pain call
and it will go to the registered numbers like ten million additional months and as soon as Enter Google
and then one hundred will go to the nearest police station or to the nearest corpse
and in this way in this shift if you just asked when does
and what do we know there were only this using this putting deceptive it just where it will.
It's not going great and I mean that it. Got boat builder dot dot dot about it. WOMAN one does.
I mean that's how we are developing for women for girls.
Fashion is a fashion statement will you know what are we design it does like a smart safety smart safety fitness watch.
Yes.
And finally we send or like in the form of a digital watch your digital watch we witness and present future pictures
and human safety features that people will wear just like you whether we're like I'd like to put this what if any kind
of I think when they can use them. So PETER SAGAL So you're pushing this brought in that in the government.
It's like you find you farmed almost the mission I'm in the market to corner the market that hasn't been covered by
others.
Yes because it has it has not because of bottom part of the sea that up witness was there some Best better
and better fitness was in the room that in many secret defeaters
but all in the one where there was not I wouldn't say everything is there. But however seemed like. When you make food.
You have the doubles and all but the least you make is innovative so how you collect vegetables and all
and now we make you feel that much of the finally how you use the. I mean. To leave.
People the spices and all that wonders how wonderful
and how you know do you made the from because every like I did they will turn small to I
but I will anyway so say me in guessable this gadget or not. So if you.
I we part and party to individual features the features would be I really would have been
but how do you know what they really were designed how like how it would be consumed how if it would one of what would
be a sequence
and whole what it is user friendly that might just sold this is the one we would look where we you know what to make it
a user friendly solution. How I mean what they're going to want like the woman and guns can properly use disguise it.
So it's kind of smooth then shall judgement. All in one. If I say no we're done. While it's if I say no. We'll need.
Fitness watch with safety features an all in one. You know what it will is I didn't find anyone.
That's why you would give a biscuit
and where you get your knowledge from I mean what what you see it all about it being what you've been saying here
and I am good in generalising the what I am an innovator. I so I've found a problem. I found. And then I.
Tried to I did a proper solution to tears.
I mean I did that you can see I saw that is a problem is encountered problems
and to dis universal to to this a good idea to discuss you know lessons in this problem is going to solve this is just
the idea that the concept that not all concept every idea actually thought that this is going to put a solution to the
problem then we do the market. Sort of in that way. That's the kind of. What about the maximum bet of.
The device which is I would the first time I'd love to solve the tax but we found that a not so great
when I was on the not so great. Gadgets which can actually solve the problem.
And then we told her we have to finally be sent something. Now I got to do it and everything.
It's obvious because I have knowledge in aversion and all but and I have the knowledge and technology as well
but by doing everything all in and I don't need medical difficult chore.
I didn't approach but what's going to make it a product. There's a question.
So now I generalized the what
but one would thing in me that I know I have the knowledge that which what has to be done not which place where the
right people the people who can do it if it be really where they are have at I believe when currently.
I have that knowledge I have that due to my experience
or due to my exposure to Bob while maybe that then has him going to be a game engine me but due to this. Sure.
Current solution for election is us. Yeah yeah. Yes yes. So yeah yeah I was saying this whole.
Finally I don't know what the right people would have read that I'm a liberal who would be able to blow a boob were
putting it up to me like some will be doing a good design.
So I foundered I have a critic being one of their designers in order to be a nurse who can act best. Who are full.
So I want to create a team to get Eleanor and like minded or go to that end of the room.
Then I keep on channeling the things.
Who would but will be in a better way then I try to combine everything will slot on my including my ideas
and universe and then what I can implement if I have done this and everyone down nuclear does most complete beam
and combine to make it one product.
So that finally it can get him back
and that's what you're saying is that you have a lot of I do years inventions you make it you take one mountain
and commercialize it but
when you look at the other inventions what were what kind of ideas started where you were sixty a part of them will
transcend this is this is more.
That I realized that film was everything all emotion all of a sudden it's very difficult to pick up the any of the Big
Sur companies like Apple and Microsoft.
You see the game the market of the one person
when the one for you can become heat success then the game with the other perhaps even with that one going to keep an
eye opening that one perhaps used to conclude up a lot of Microsoft
or anyone who does it with they have in one part of the focus of the one program
and bozo school for most of the one product and then the one who is creating millions and millions of impact.
So I was particular that if I only create the impact at a global level I felt for most of the one point zero if that is
because everybody nation will be a part of your part of the it was as I have done so far I am looking that I will with
bio tech but related to any of the combinations the universities
and again I want to the venue what I can do that you know and I will do it to be licensed by any of the type
or to go on a sun audit with the collaboration wheat. So modernizing that we can add some.
Unit we can add some value or to that program and they can or the low side vendor to the bar and we jointly we can.
Call them that in the joint. For the call much later.
Not by licensing unpredictable type but they are going to some in this way
or that in the innovation is going to get into the market
and that would create impact if I was in that from my other than a set up from my own company.
I am going to push is very difficult and that is everything will go to get dished up.
I understand that but that's a lot of people who have these ideas. Why is it that you were awarded so many awards.
And the way I visualize and imagine a particular problem
and I've found it effective solution for that it's all about we let you know listen is going to solve the problem
and how soon be paid to universities how innovative the idea is if you dig everything into the gun to do this
and that's where it's being. I wondered by the butts enough in the that I want to conceal what I want to fly so.
So that you know diminishment just like the house at the young age House simplified I began to assume that I would have
done with more in a computer minus. It's all about to seem very innocent gets a great sense. That's why we're bored.
Yeah you could say. And do you agree with that because you were awarded.
You know because not fasting I'm going up
and the big I was thinking that there are many more great you know what does that on many more universal.
I mean gadgets which other far complicated and then my innovations.
But why are I what I want it and obviously the people who get I want to do it wouldn't lot of talent to do the memos
and all that who they should give the body the clues mean
and I will do the something in a sense something that MS they have found that you know listen then I mean.
Then they don't come Dame out from someone I came to know that is is me I want to because how simply the problem is
being solved and that they get it if you know how you do differently the universities and those universes.
Yes I want to because that is W. No sense that going that he would cook I mean the kind of scenario.
And it's not about oil.
It was a computer know sort of simplifying a listen and be able to tell me
and explain a bit more of the innovations you you were awarded for you have the wheelchair
and you have the work of our innovation. Your invention. Yes. Well be able to design a low cost.
Electricity is just dumb like you would a great efficiency molest a little input and a great great represents a lot.
So it's going to in the near what what we have value add to that in the most news that only a few primitives site
enough to build on the back to can be kept in a cycle Cadia only programmer cycling going to noone can get in there
don't let the shooting.
So that you know what you miss we did is that telling that we have overcome by admitting that you know us
and that same as you and with which we do so for such kind of there's a gadget.
Now there are many better that actually are doing those days since Piper six are stable like we did to get there to
where we can all put it on the computer and laptop applications without using in keyboard
and most of the computer you want on most to transport we're near we'll get it just like we just act everything in the
air and. Add.
On the companies feel like I would be a killer doctor that clearly I would make I can do everything and do so
and that I was able to do.
No one was a weird look but it was not the universe I'm on now in that I do not need you know some scheme.
So in this way that a lot of the you know since like one brainless cute like them because we know that that message
also no doubt about the cost and design. It's one.
If you pull one some more designs of the god or something they can or get it.
I was the girl I was there but but it is there by that particular god
and it is difficult that if the vision is to reduce world accidents which of his own is to reduce traffic jams and all.
So even if we have to be the Davis.
It's not only wonder who they can get but I list is not possible when everyone can
or afford to have it in one cannot expense that in their driver.
Everyone will not sell their own got to get their Davis Cup so we are putting each and every one. So what.
Like I don't.
It could get would be then which can be implemented you need to enable to make it even this last week
and even if someone is within your local to make a living that can be the keep going to be one in from the low
but hey can we show that is more than millions and those make it.
We're going to do or Davis into making a better Scotland and make it good then
and we can make it out of this one so that is when we will listen to the more mobility industries.
And what your role in that will be done and design the cute.
So we're looking that we can license to any type of automobile industry so that they can get in the market we don't
want will cost less does you know us and what makes you want. What makes it Indian what you're doing.
It's so specific that.
You have to go see in the only not more traffic jams
and the number up in causing a lot of road accident is more as compared to the. Other developed countries.
You know zero management
and one is that really getting caught up on what are the potential areal you can see the profit down ten dollars is a
matter of concern so to solve that I feel that it's good to get insured we need to name the bacon.
It's really what you see in your daily life in India is you're trying to focus on what I was.
But what I do when I'm in winning something I'm looking at the global aspect how did in global You did it is
when we came back and it all the people start from one place. So I've been in India and I'm looking at how fast I will.
There was no I don't get the impact in India then. The same thing I can replicate book back.
And on the Hill because everyone is a human human being
and I believe that human humanity matters in what way is meditation helping you to find solutions.
Now obviously because I'm labelled a teen there beyond me in my.
Innocent in up that level that what kind of you know sin is going to solve the problem.
It's not a not one might it won't work.
So dot com is that extra that power is required to clean different protein that is unique.
So I feel that because of that I'm able to team beyond my imagination.
We have beyond our capacity we may be different from people to people but I feel that that helps me
or drives me to you know what something really what's happening where your military career explaining what's what's
going on in your head when I see. I'm able to feel a stone next five.
I will I will be able to visualize movies and let me visit I like I would be delusional in Baghdad.
Fifty million users swallowed way in the next five years so I'm able to visualize Denmark what how we are going in.
We're going inside that sun all wrong. Like we should do next.
And we will see that in a plan of a dream or in the form of a video but I want to see when I'm closing my eyes
and I will see that.
And yes but I want to we have to show now we have going in this direction or there is some problem
and it was a simple dish that it's something that we should do the usual morning back.
So I will do standup five years we've done what we don't know where we are standing right here.
Boom or stand at this point. So how this can multiply all that impact we're creating from a million little billions.
So how it can I just we were able to visualize that and we have difficulty of his them
and we are sure that if you add to that vision in the next five years people even at even the heat.
If you will it will do at least fifty percent of our vision if you. In the in the next five years.
Then you can multiply it to billions in the next five or the next day and if you can if you want to lead.
We are I mean ultimately going to pull them out of the studio tool that noise which we created it rip.
If you are going to get more to play.
So we don't need to enforce bull in bed billions if we can impact millions than are going to go.
You do want to go to billions. You say visualize with what happens in your head explain the different steps.
Yeah these three hours for human creation actually in a spiritually we have to look at us like I had on the help of
people like you know like we have all the seven circles legs gets a little leg.
We can stick it on but all in English and that and that and that is. It took us up toward this is to the heart.
So you stuck close up and as I used you can see all these sickos when you where did some there's some actual
and those in the universe. So when you met or did when you used like I'm actually you. I would.
I don't want to nominate it was a month
and he said he can one thing I do generally so in that I just grasp what the cost me going to do to my body
and in that process obviously that you know that come into play here will do this last put
and in the general a shuttle will outline what I'm an energy guest plus boarding the body then it's dished up if it
will go and moment.
So their energies that helps you build then that strength and that confidence that or whatever development of good
and that confidence he has this is you can you can actually you'll get the power to pick the right decision
and the right thing that's most important the people who are success brought to this scenario because of making the
right decision of the right thing. So that things that you want it will get that confidence that the that I did.
We're taking this is the right thing.
Google the statement when I feel that it happens when that and then does anyone food believed what he did
and there is this and that into the body for that. And yes you can feel that he.
For doing properly and it's three hours a day.
I don't go to one five hours you can see there are a lot of us through hard times I don't know what arguments
and then you're completely.
Yeah he gets your computer then I've let the progress in and out and and of these created I.D.'s I would.
I'm going to do if I planned this I would give this that and my love
and know that I my God that extra boost in center will move that with great force to achieve that vision
and every day I'm doing something that live with that vision is one day is getting at you every day every day.
Why I'm just putting a broad broad drop of of that before you feel that prism. Where you.
And when you could explain that vision. WHAT THAT YOU HAVE WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT IS IT.
The vision you have where are you in five twenty years. Yeah.
In the next five years we have just realizing bring back fifty million.
I mean you just in the next five years and back to the fifty million users obviously
and back to about E two in a list of US products.
So we are now making the product in such a word that it is going to be in I mean that millions of people are going to
buy this product they would like to feel that they had that some space settled by which your film made them feel that
what I was that special. If that what this device so made to made them that freed.
So we're just trying to create packaging in such a way that the people who just love to get this product will be
getting this product. So we're doing that so.
And we're going to couple of months we will do this and we will just put this product to market
and then it will just want to play but we're like from legs to premiums that means it will keep on increasing.
But yes indeed there would have been after we like this like this ups and downs will come
but we should make sure that if we get some critics and all.
We'll keep on doing then go to bed and that we're going to buy the fish things but do not a lot of trials
and we are what about to what the critics we're getting we're just improving their will in Bloomfield.
But we're just beside the a few details in the press and they were designed about what we'll do
and we'll put that in print of the public and public with with a proper set that you were sixty eight years ago.
So you have no nature for you. You have twenty five people working with you.
Where do you make your money of the last eight years. Yes you.
Obviously our programs are not to monitor but we're fact are creating a noise of the product
and this is going to belong to the market that triage on the people the money we're getting is through.
To confidence in business which is the secondary business model. I'm going to say. Of a lot of them.
Isn't that like it's in the name of it in construction
and Cecil would do something continence type of projects for the industries but corporates for the government
and to deal in revenue it becomes one of the revenue source for the company eyes of the president
and second it creates an experience or two about demon or who made them head free on that you know sense
and because they're here today was play knowledge and experience by doing that.
And we take such put their suites will help us to make up artist because we don't do every kind of confidence a
business. We're very focused in even if we're doing it.
Confidence had been there before but that which kind of innovations.
We will take from other planes and would produce which would help us what the mood good experience
or that they can do value about you know our products and what kind of comes up because of the Seas. Very general.
Yes although we are into Iraq. I would be solutions. I mean those are my sons in law.
We have possession of these areas or commissions. I would be solutions.
I look at approaches that a lot many things happen
but we have mainly focused with these if any of the problem in the US
and that has any of those sectors like me make any sound on we just outsource it will some other organized on the part
of our partners on. And looking at yourself as a person sixty years you were first aboard at seventeen I think.
I play sixteen sixes you were awarded.
And then what kind of award to go to afterwards to someone like we're going to go.
I mean not sign on the so many I want it.
Haven't I want to start on because when you what I wanted was an automatic
and obviously in the you would have to boost me too but I wondered next and so you would actually explain
when you get past that I wondered. So you learned that she would have to get a faster one you would up.
I do so many failures that clearly is also that she meant what I feel and fail means fast I can be learning.
If I am so that you should accept something so you will learn through prayer and words alone by actually being dead.
So you are particular of What Not To Do and What.
So what would you not do and what is what you do yes by commenting that
when I did I do just that comment what I did then when I think of anyone in a verse
and I are paired board with the things that when I'm doing this in a Muslim. What didn't.
So I'm not a doing what should I do.
And by the by the platoon in this part like Mark Cuban whatnot do all the you know in a sense what I'm doing
and I got our scene.
When I saw that I sense and and I sometimes International when I was in prison
and where you would sum up briefly what kind of innovations and inventions you did. Can you tell me.
One settles things first the town can begin a long.
OK Fight like one is the inability can say like the bits of which I don't which I just described one is a low cost.
I mean one get one low cost accidental secondly because in hilly areas of a coast in a fall from the mountains because
of the air and water here and all night because the roads are not visible properly and fell from the mountain.
So that no good design to keep that can be implemented in a vehicle by which the vehicle will stop him.
There is no place to move if there is a hole or there's a period where there is that if there is a board
and if there is more on the side of the vehicle responds and then it drips lately move back and put a brick.
Are your brother young.
Yes you are and one of the local system I called it for the for the villagers and for the road end but
when we did that.
Device I mean the heat which can from our electrical of Willis's at the very a powerful place then we did not drive
less cute which can implement in a vacant pool. He and I mean to me to completely. And I've discovered. Yes.
Then we've designed.
A good was going to implement that in any of the home where nobody will be inside the home a lot in terms of room there
will be electrical appliances will be active when nobody will listen to them.
Illiterates they don't will automatically put off because generally we for fun of the device and or
when they were in the line lighting to be there when they were not there and lighting soon get off.
I don't very low cost it after the race. And then. And then some innovations which is not. Exactly. Yeah I mean useful.
For the public directly
but some you know so it's like photo what educational couple you know as we do we do some who create these you know the
other universes which is something that we have you know since we're just going to create interest in the youth sports
technology lets you know us since we started it and don't have a dad when we go to try it and win for it.
Like who fought for the entertainment but it was for the.
Educational but it was and doing the same in us with I'm invited as a guest because in college.
It's not incorporated taught in schools.
I used to discuss let's get hits and that creates interest in the youth to us you know Wes on the storage technology
and all. And so you know most of like there drone that can be operated through my hands.
But I don't know my hand are going to move.
And there's I designed the Iron Man three person
and to my heartbeat if I am because my heart hard to beat then the repros are we going to do it and hand end up to par.
So we get back to it so did others from you know Muslims which is I mean he had interest
and he would because they can connect with just so he did it.
I mean that literally pushed us that this was just in in in a they believe you don't mean a movie
but then all of that and what and when they see that that has been a real fall in the public universe
and so the thing that you know so is so wonderful so beautiful so kind of different in that you know most of these
technologies are really interesting. So they have been given my best and at what they can with in a sense. Accordingly.
I mean we're going to hear these examples which are very nice
but I also think immediately over the life you know that there are three of them the U.S.
Succeeded in Europe but you know. So what. Why don't they import that in India.
Instead of waiting for your invitations to be made see that might be something that was always public or didn't matter.
One pond had been a part of it or done which I have done.
But it's all about the best two hundred best in the in the customer in the other you off your target customer.
When you go in there was a new sign of what are the custom of their target audience.
I'll give an example and from that example you will find the answer.
I mean what I like finally the big sample of Amazon and people. I mean there and then what other great company.
I mustn't is obviously here
and don't enable one was that bloody one thing you can find in India also there is a lot of competition like this.
Amazon that is so I mean in India.
I mean I already under no doubt about there are some in India the people that is not doing that are many e-commerce
companies flipper was the one who admittedly captured the Indian market fast
and why because of the one simplified feature that included Amazon is part of the much better
and big dent clip got a few wins in captured in the Indian market because the bottom the co-founder of the
or not of the flipper it is.
India
and he thought that what that you know what the future then we've done that added best in in the field for that at an
outpatient space where the people would like to be debt free and what do you do.
He just included gas
and anybody up some which I don't include written now on what's what that thing he didn't include at COD up some
and people.
Admittedly for that paper because Indians People generally don't burst on eco most if they if we have passed then they
are to get the products in India people feel their hand to hand give the product they take the money so that one piece
of that created it would he when he kept it to completely the Indian market.
So the person who was to hire their working for my unit was on the one that I am looking into that I am adding such
features which is part of whom I am part of getting the. The question was I mean my target goes.
I'm once in a particular area to whom I am going to be pretty fit was that these are the look that got so much more I
am focusing on. Yes let's say and I'm starting from Indians. Then when I'll go to the global level. I would add AK.
Accordingly if I'm doing. If I'm looking into E.U. Worse. I will absolutely do something this in the features.
If I look in the Saudi.
Are Arab countries I'll do something this in the features so from different players from like there is in Hindi there
is a big step when they decide this. Most of his like of how the new players new people.
So you have to act accordingly. At what their test and on you have to modify so.
Where before I mean new players then with new people. So people.
I mean look but I mean one product will be like when young men are to be led by the decisive men
and led by people in the US. The product which you would like a US men are to be liked by Indians.
So the probably have to keep on sending you a small mountain dislikable if you are tending from Target customer then
you know that it's on the you of of the most when you see Indian. A.B.C.
Food from your future when it's us it should be B. C. D. If it is British terms it may be the so indirectly.
So if I'm focusing Indian stuffy nose or not focus in the other
but other than focusing on this for the because I pondered this A.B.C.
Is going to attack them or will interest in them.
It's as simple as this
and she sort of the uniqueness is also if you were in the for example this hospital looking at this man Dr needing a
wheelchair but he didn't move himself I'm saying more mending there should be affordable.
If the import of those things with the doctor may cost more than two lots of three legs on the other half a million
school at least there no doubt this will to which I have no valid reason low cost is affordable that I keep I even I
give flexible. I give flexible off sounds like both of the parts of the which you need.
You can get but get a place of your own. For going to going to hell and going to get discouraged.
You can bear down you can operate or electrical appliances you can actually say this if you want to move on.
We can design in local after the world will tell you and your customers will
and we can implement of keeping the wheelchair.
So that providing the space cell of simple the that it was done on makes them feel special
and they choose you would rather than to any others why they would invest such.
I mean what money if they're getting the special thing and after the race. So I know that what exactly is going to.
Attack them in unconscionable and how many will churn owners
or people that are good produce able are usually your can guarantee there will be more then one day I can see what will
be this is not a product which. I don't own brand. So doing the politicians until some tie up more than a sense.
I mean.
There's just the devil of some of the units and we help them in developing those bits of cures
and it was being either destroyed by many of the you just maybe to a gimme some sort of industry
but obviously we don't come much less in this universe
and we are just seems to have met a company so that they can become a slave in a button with. Color choices. This. And.
When you look around below who are your heroes. If you were in your vision somebody that you would like to be.
You think warm embrace of that's what people and everyone sort of people I mean he knows.
Responses of people I learn what to do and every from every sort of people I learn what NOT to do this.
Legace
and people are going to like Bill Gates Steve Jobs each one of them like Elon Musk like these people are massive You
don't know what will I learn everything I would like how they are to struggle stays in all London what are the things
which they make mistakes and the need to restart from that and from there I suppose I don't know.
But I assume not when my True Blood so that I can start to live without hardly itch. If I'm if I'm there.
If I have something on the young is because of that I would try to learn from other states Prince what I would have
done by which they've got and I wonder I'm going to bed got to achievement.
So now you know if you take the example in most like to people what I want to hear out on get on one fifteen million
dollars a year on where you will be up on the computer models and as Space X. We don't know the impulse buy.
You did he even didn't say every single penny.
I mean he bought of that and those days he was brought in from his friends and he was staying in a rented homes.
I don't know what he did what he bought
but I think he was more forced to live use them even you don't want to say in his pocket.
I've seen a single before you can invest that to fulfill his vision he did that he was completely involved in
fulfilling his vision small part in many maybe done what I feel that what we have done is an eight from where you put
it on yourself What makes you a visionary for others who think. See I don't want to see every human being.
Tenting their lives with us live where I live should have a bungalow easy drive a car he will have a vacant lot we will
need a lot more left and everyone watched it
but there are some people who are to their day live just for cause death there how we're going back to that.
How in the world going to be the house how we've been getting there.
But our dream God but how we'll have a lot of bank balance the focus to debt and.
Some people want that kind of life but I'm not focusing on that I know dirty play.
I don't focus movies and everything will come every dream will put in that place.
So everything we put in the place I born in before cause.
How much my bank will learns how much software that I would have had their dream house on order whether I managed
or not I would have a dream car not.
I don't need to focus that I know that this all this recess and all the dreams we fulfil apply to fulfill my vision.
If I stick to my visa. It's everything will get put in my bag.
So this all will be pulled in many so I'm just kind of yes I know that I was going to say that
but focusing on the visa.
So if I had to step out of the zone everything will be and very but I want real happiness that I'm going to get is
when the vision is fulfilled when everyone. If I find a new one. Someone said I saw you just joined my life.
You know wasn't easy to change my life.
The doctors said you might see me rather than that seeing of these and this but how dream.
That is my dream also dream God if I get a statement now to some this universe and a zealot in my life.
Thank you so much. My head that I hear this small children from my use of I'm more than happy.
And good but then so why are you in the eyes of other people visionary.
Because I have my reason why I am every day much of that the words I do now gives when you add to the vision
and what I would like to decide do I used every day one led out of the end of the vision
and people can always see that if I wouldn't be seen by others then that's why they feel that I was in a.
So we will be the next your most probably yeah I know I would love to hear.
First of all you want to tell someone about. Bigger example. Yes You ask whether I want to be a the next.
And I must I would say yes I want to be done next. And I must cover India.
I can sing because I don't want to see the dearly get upset an entrepreneur and past. I want to be myself.
I want to be son but Nick was the best suited to the next day and in most of India.
So obviously it would mean uniqueness with me some university of my own to put on mine.
Obviously I mean if I were able to fulfill that vision that ability of the vision family able to impact millions of
lives the lives of like and obviously it will mean that it's died pushing it would not be good and would.
Just happen in the world are you just mentioned before that pull in but with wild right in the next five years then
and obviously to rebuild lives would be your key would is that if that was any that's it in the next five years.
What kind of problems you encounter here in India.
I suppose it's one success story or I've received the phone to find problems and you should come to India.
I can see because that is a lot on and to problems.
I had seen that if that is a problem then that's sad to me because that is when the things that we can learn
and look when the things we can explore and develop a new bit we can use out of mind.
There was something was going to solve that and cover problem and that problem
and maybe did it go into if you will be pushed by the other parts of the world as it so that can get him back in that
day as I was about to anyone that is in India is not only solving the problems of Indian people it is also so in the
lives of the global people as with so you are she Indian problems and trying to find solutions for that. Exactly. And.
Only question what are what makes more you invent more unique than water already exists in the world.
See I don't focus on hole and put it in over to me I've done in the universe
and it happened splendidly let you know what happened there. Depends to make it more user friendly.
I just group will make and he was a friend
and one group we could create a universe of if something that is similar to the existing universe
and if my notion has some extra one features. I like them I can get in a listen. And let live.
But was that it was of the market with them individually whether to me or the nascent company or the tool type idea
and I don't know what the interest in the quote I was with all that on automation such companies.
So if they didn't buy every wedding that is one featured in the universe
and they were just really creating it in back then I would like to post it if it should more than make it easier for
internet or than we can get to great company of us and school. So it happens when I'm focusing committed to. U.E.
User friendly it becomes the innovation. I write for the series we filmed in the most moral lapse.
You can't imagine like the unique. Yesterday in the fact that I have to admit it was not a most modern and.
How is that from the fact I love the music of a sheet.
Yeah that's we updated a clear close and make a space step a place where I don't make it.
We just want to make the people like to make you know what those will do
and upsets people less of us in such lab we just provide. Oh you just give me a list and I say lab.
I mean they can access the lab equipments
and they can do something they can advance from that I guess build prototypes
and products like yesterday you filmed art
and you saw that how there are some different take on Social what we in some to do different things.
So we're just bright look at ecosystem where the other makers and other you know what this will come
and you know it's more than likely. One space.
So people can go and get something that they were glad they would have to process
but finally they will do something that is going to greatly impact.
So that's a place if it's blessed with all provided by the young and then they will then when they would come.
In that doctors are for peace.
So if they wish to keep struggling to do then obviously if they are in their time and effort
and creating that space then they were started in the new project under a lot of pain
and efficiency are degrees so you know how did these guys don't need to get I mean they had to watch space which we
have already created so there's a need to exclude that ideas into products and push to the market
and we will help provide that because this time.
That meant that tantalizing ecosystem that getting value of what I was on ecosystems language that can.
It was going to get in the market are possible to start bits of the television experience you had with so it's it's
good to have a bit of a clumsy kind of luck because then you can discover and understand is that right.
And obviously when there are more and more like we even blood that make us
and you know what does we will come out the middle because I don't know what will walk out on under one umbrella
and obviously the ecosystem where we can discuss each other we can get it. We can create critics.
And finally of best result will come out of there. When you develop and they will obviously.
It's like you create a place where you from your vet you can research the television. Yes. It's something over there.
When you when I hear you.
Your best dancer who does you have your friends open
or close close close so these the eyes closed so it will open the polls open up on their own home. I should open it up.
Please as it will.
You know we don't have to do it again but I mean is that just from from our audience are very open to that.
So you know that's that's what's our responsibility. So when you talk you talk like a person with local experience.
If you're only twenty four years old
but I have seven year sixpence in the field of you know since I don't are going to wait and see.
A lot of them obviously I would have been corporate governance of a company. In things I was struck by consent.
I would you know what percentage in things. And I wish one is empowered in future. So we have incorporated last year.
Let me put off he said in governing which started the journey and.
Lot of struggles and all of that gives us a experience and by exposing.
There's a lot of explain to us and we must do we had a long nose when the when and when if when we.
But it's to the experts and we had it. When the learning acted too late. About a possible come about for us to even to.
If I'm able to learn something from to live with what more than a better than what we wish you know I'm getting a
chance to learn if I'm interacting with us.
They are learning from me and I was learning from them so that learning attitude we keep
and actually I think we are progressing and I did some very very self one of the new way forward in the I form.
What did you learn personally. From the lots.
As you were from still quite young when you started to succeed with your first invention corpse. What did you want.
What makes you so successful. So I just follow my passion past my passion is this technology.
You know I'm just one of my passion and I'm just being a pass on to a profession and that's it and I really.
That's from his past is in the subset of people that fill in the heart Money comes
and I'm the where if pledge on the Soul that is never a matter of his will because you might be doing something which
you want on the millions but even when you're following a passion. What do you want on the list.
But despite some of his foot in the past. Unless it's absolutely with us.
He's happy
and despite all of us one thing we probably every night two hundred become competent at least every night the person
will hunting.
I mean hunting when I have my list like in his dreams maybe so he hasn't had a knot or poor dad some of it.
He was interested or he didn't follow his best and he might he would one might and he might want to be a good writer
but he was being some in ninety five job or he got a better job in any ministry. He's running late.
Every month but he will to get it repaired or degrade will keep on hunting every night bear.
He didn't follow his bison. So I'd better not get the feeling that you follow the pass on and follow the heart.
And that's what you're doing in that where if you let em sex will lead that is things like how where that how much
you're creating very gotta how much Donovan of done how much money you you alone.
Will be just a part of the life and that is going to happen time
and time so I really wish it was modeled that we should focus on what I do forming a pass on
and clip on how you are making them better. Nice to you and. Can you give me. What for you. I'm sorry for you.
The magic word. I mean clearly you do your work really think wow is this.
Drives Me seen all of us keep exposure sometime use of that that's what I learn and it vital to our inner demon
or even national a lot of us and they rightly would expect isms not to be effectiveness and to be expected
when you put yourself with a guy that he lets you would or you wouldn't
but it is more time that he lets it because you are going to prove it is a difference.
I will ask my hand I will thing that I still if there's a what about him I would ask my hand
and get that part of her to me so I will go and get a good daughter when I do come now that is it if I expect that.
I will ask you that you weren't going to talk about her for me that books and that would bother you
when you get to that option for nor even asking their dad what order for me.
If I asked my stepson one get it out of the door for me so that dance is more his
and more suited I can get a daughter with him. So it will give expert on New Years with anybody.
If you are not able to explain to them how you are going to thing that
or how you would to measure improvement from that museum. So that's the little one whom we are expecting is.
Is it a matter of them some.
We are or the series of every episode has an arch dark markets are and you are and are the maker.
You know you are you are you really without Yeah I am him because maybe it is also you know her does it make you a
creative soul. He has a free body is free.
You could do what he wants he played havoc and all but finally that I don't matters
when you are on entrepreneurs you are creating impact you make art graceful.
How can anything destroy anything peered in that thing without focusing that way that it is going to be back on his
or straight with your do while we picked out of the notes and we typing when you do does shooting in the Fabulous.
You see that of how differently. We have done something you know since and on. How badly.
Just so kind of do not even see it would try to solve the part of the problem in that perspective dying what we didn't
do didn't. What was it how that these things are going to great impact but finally you up at dawn and on entrepreneurs.
If we want to make it to the I mean to the global people.
So I make our professional model what finally I'll put I'm an entrepreneur had gotten better by being unable to
inaudible creating impact. OK Thank you. But for us or for us.
Could you explain what is the difference in innovating for Indian markets comparing it to other markets worldwide
or the U.S. Market from what's the difference between the innovations.
What is the difference for innovating for Indian markets.
Comparing it to other markets for what makes Indian markets are all different from call for specially if all of the
mentioned the C.
You know us
and we at that audience are the as I to get the product you have to make them that feel that I should get a program to
see everyone pull that one something if in the idea of the need of what I want them.
This the absence of such clarity is like they should get more quantity
but quality they should get out from the old place.
So you know this keeps on credit as if there is a good actor to any of the perp
and MOST him apart from this tweet most important is that if we knew as anyone is a reference reporting is giving the
money of that product if any of his friends is how do you know that this explains what I want is that he also then.
And that in the end is going to get that product which is friend but I thought so that
when I was about Bob published the matters fast and then didn't get into the other but it did.
I'm talking of the misery. Not every one of them is a pretty.
So your profit would you know it's such a level where it would get into my it would create a noise.
It would get into the people's multiplicity itself make them feel that special tool that they can do source in Indians
people talk over the i Pads in pretty high when he lets people know who the actually quit i Pads.
While many people the part of that we CAN I thought I
and I saw sometime I feel that Apple makes us proud of to to give it messes that you don't have your own value.
Get out get our product that in because of having sometimes a lot of the U.I.
and I mean we maybe don't but I put that in it and that embed happens more than Indians.
There are people who don't even need to use a phone properly did just know how to call they don't know
but he was absent anything not to get a phone does produce wealth they feel that they're valuing because by getting
such products. I will not get that burn.
It's a great product but if you really don't take it if you are utilizing all the features
and what is dear are those going to simple fun if you just want to make a call
and we really don't know what he's going to make you should search for the Indian markets.
Instead of other companies that come from abroad. So obviously being an Indian and I know them.
I understand the mentality of the Indians.
I know what they exactly once and what I still include in a product so that they will be easily fascinated
or they will be easily at record words a product that will make them feel special.
So everything I am putting into the consequentialism. So like if people.
Coming from Abu Wilton to make a program to put in the market.
They don't understand exactly unmentioned Now you can see just recently example of Apple.
There's just because the place of the upper and use the rest of the volume.
Does that I mean the volume sales increased drastically. So there might be some Indian in there in the apple.
In the apple in the out of what I want to say one of those are going to turn in
and it will move out about kidnapper might have suggested that if you were Buddhists then this then that it was going
to Destin only includes a number of sales in India.
So if you want to because of the number Indians and you know it's a great market like it's more than one million.
Populous on.
I mean we I mean if you annoy India so to them that is more in film I mean the in a person is more than one we until
that is more school.
How do you go and are you going to say look progress in the Indian market so if you follow some that I'm going to us
and that in I'm going to the main thing is that the obviously if you are from Netherlands then.
You know but what product.
One has to be done then that is going to model at the Netherland audience on the net and people I get and
when I enter the get up muscles focus product we do that
and then if you if there are companies in the US who are out
and I saw a part of your body is going to say what do you want to be in India. If I make a product which your pardon.
Maybe one hundred times better than my part of what I would be including some in that part of my part is one percent
for sale because I was going that when we attack in the Indian mindset. You are.
I don't know many
but I meant is that age should be such a word that it will get them out publicly then the local one might not like to
get the i Phone out to get us. Samsung Galaxy phone. It's a much more costly and then in pocket money that. Scared.
I mean there are some home video and home.
There and there but but but but all promptly and they add all the pocket monies and all but they get their i Phone
or this Galaxy phone. Because that has created a noise and there. That has created royalty. A while for you.
If a million friends community if you are using i Phone not going to get special treatment for the home policy what you
have by phone while you office. Samsung phone. Samsung Galaxy top people appreciate. So the dad.
Did it and there will be some other some students will be jealous that you people have that his friend has a i Phone
and i don't have to dead jealousy that to prove that royalist people.
Buy the product and that doctors mold their stuff casting by with people.
But is that part of the people who are really required.
I have coming into the second video to democracy is a past master says that that creates a did did not create a
delicacy. If if you approach.
If someone is pulling a really special and after sitting
and they are feeling the loss that this person has that product.
Well it is creating a while we fit everyone is uplifting Wow you have the spirit of so that jealousy would make others
to get that part of. I learn from whens I do in the company will be manifesting that part of wins.